direction le tribunal à présent où
quatre prévenus étaient attendus à la
barre pour une affaire rocambolesque ils
sont mis en cause pour enlèvement et
tentative d'extorsion avec violence en
janvier 2022 un homme aurait demandé à
trois amis de l'aider à récupérer 11000
€ qu'il avait prêté à une connaissance
ils auraient embarqué en voiture SEP
personnes avant qu'elle ne prennent la
fuite et finisse par porter plainte
contte-rendu de l'audience avec Lucas
Chopin c'est une audience un peu
particulière qui s'est déroulée tour
aujourd'hui dans le box et sur le banc
des prévenus quatre hommes mis en cause
notamment pour enlèvement séquestration
et tentative d'extorsion avec violence
et en face une partie civile absente
absente par craânte de représaille
depuis l'effet il a déjà changé deux
fois le numéro parce qu'il reçoit des
menaces parce qu'il reçoit des appels en
inconnu voilà il sait qu'il peut y avoir
d'autres personnes que les prévenus dans
le public qui pourrai être identifié qui
pourrait être victime d'autres faits
donc tout simplement il est il est
terrifié à l'idée de se rendre à à
l'audience et l'histoire a de quoi
impressionner nous sommes en janvier
2022 abdella doit encore 11000 € à amine
pour des paris sportifs lequel se rent à
son domicile avec trois amis il l'emmène
en voiture et abdella réussit à se
sauver par la suite il porte plainte et
assure avoir été passé à tabac si
l'instigateur de l'opération reconnaît
les faits et dit les regretter il ni
cependant toute contrainte ou l'inchage
pour son avocat il s'agit en réalité
d'une histoire assez banale vous avez
une personne qui a prêté de l'argent à
un individu qui a prêté de l'argent au
mauvais individus et qui n'a pas employé
les bonnes méthodes pour retrouver la
somme qui lui était d et si vous voulez
vous êtes face à quelqu'un qui n'a pas
eu les recours habituels parce qu'il n'a
pas cette éducation et parce qu'à un
moment donné l'instinct parle lorsque
vous avez besoin de cette argent pour
les prévenus il s'agirait donc d'un
concours de circonstances je voulais lui
parler pas employer la manière forte mes
amis ne sont venus qu'au C où explique
àine justement pour l'un des avocats de
la défense cette affaire va beaucoup
trop loin contte tenu des faits pendant
les faits les services de police vont
intervenir vont procéder au contrôle de
l'ensemble des prévenus aujourd'hui et
vont laisser repartir tout ce petit
monde très gentiment après le contrôle
des identités de chacun que nos clients
ils livrent leurs identités ça veut dire
donc qu'ils ont rien à se reprocher de
son côté la procureur de la République
reconnaît que le mécanisme de cette
affaire est simple il avait une dette de
11000 € il se doutait que ça ne pouvait
pas bien tourner pour autant elle parle
bien de voyou des voyous récidivistes
elle réclame donc des peines allant de
une à 4 années de prison ferme